have you ever wondered how terraform
detects if a given resource creation
depends on another resource watch this
short to find out the answer
terraform can handle two types of
dependencies implicit and explicit
implicit dependencies are known to
terraform and are detected automatically
for example a compute instance must be
created after VPC because this is
implicit of terraform the order you
write your infrastructure code is not
important
explicit dependencies are unknown to
terraform and must be configured
explicitly using the depends on argument
for example let's say You must create
two VMS a server and a client and you
want the client VM only to be created
after the server VM is successfully
created this dependency is not visible
to terraform and has to be explicitly
mentioned are you ready to learn more
click on the three dots and then click
on the link in the description box to
enroll in the getting started with
terraform for Google Cloud course see
you there